[Music]
the tools of my trade are satellite
collars
[Music]
here she goes
start getting locations and find out
where she migrates
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's like sending yourself a christmas
present in the mail i put this collar on
and we do it in march by july it'll be
fun to open up the box and see where
that thing went
ever since yellowstone was created
people have known about the elk
migration but it's been difficult to see
it in its entirety
in the case of the cody herd they spend
half their year out on this patchwork of
private ranches and state lands in the
spring they all start migrating towards
the forest boundary pretty soon they're
getting to the yellowstone national park
boundary once they cross into the park
they're arriving at their summer ranges
where they spend the other half of their
year
the gps collars i put on elk let me see
incredible detail but that's still a far
cry from going there myself and seeing
the migration first hand
so that's what i'm going to do this
summer
joe's bringing his camera traps to set
along the trails james is bringing his
paintbrush and an artist's eye
in the end we also want to be able to
share this with other people
i've been photographing migrations for a
long time and this is the first time
i've focused on elk
the only way to see and show migration
is with camera traps
[Music]
perfect bear nap place if i was a bear i
would nap in there
we are on the east side of yellowstone
national park
[Music]
we're in the winter range now
[Music]
the first elk i saw were while trout
fishing in the west
[Music]
we need beautiful things
the planet would be a pale and
uninspiring place without things like
trout
for me anyway
[Music]
it's fun working at james i mean i find
myself bringing you know hey james paint
this you know why don't you add this
what about this ladybug
wildflowers
rocks
fish
he notices things that we don't notice
and
you know pulls us back out into the
broader view
[Music]
you know if i'm painting a trout i'm
also kind of painting
an elk because they've walked through
this territory
as we come to learn more about the
movements of animals you realize that
everything is connected with everything
else around the planet so if
yellowstone's come to mean
a box with stuff in it
then maybe we have to work to make that
word mean something else
[Music]
all right how you doing
good morning
jesus that's a nice cow there
[Music]
actually all ranchers
will tell you we don't raise cattle
we raise trash
the herds are on these ranches for half
their lives this is where they get food
and shelter during the harsh winter
total amount of land that you guys are
managing
255 000 acres in wyoming
actually
i think it broadens an appreciation to
know that okay this is a part of
something a lot bigger than just our
activities on the ranch
we're on the edge of the yellowstone
ecosystem you know we're really part of
it
that's the wild wild place just living
around the wilderness areas just right
above us all around us
we're surrounded by public land too and
it borders and the elk moved through it
and this fall we had you know over a
hundred animals grazing you kind of have
to
try to plan for that
you know the fencing we had to redo all
of our fencing so that they don't get
caught up in it make it easy for them to
move through
being out there seeing all this being
you know kind of sharing their habitat
listening to bull elk bugling out your
backyard it's good
[Music]
now we're leaving the ranch lands and
we're going to start making our way up
into the mountains
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're pretty far away from yellowstone
right here
we gotta migrate
[Music]
[Music]
the absorker mountains are rugged
they're steep they're dry they're
scrabbly and so the only way we can do
it with our gear and efficiently is on
mules and horses
[Music]
looking for joe's cameras he had five
cameras up here
the last one has gone missing
seems like some elk
or a bear
came through and knocked a lot of these
cameras around and we found the other
ones
can't find this one
[Music]
is that a lens sticking up down there
in the mud yeah
that's not good way to go joe
i didn't think i was gonna find this one
it's probably the first bump
it eliminates the front lens element
but i mean it's either
we put it on the cliff and take the risk
of getting
amazing elk migration footage or we
don't do it yeah
and we decided to do it
we'll clean them up and see if we can
get them back out
we might have to just do without the
that
just do without that
this
yeah that front
all right we better get moving so we can
get over the needle which is
not even in sight at this point
look at that pile out coming over the
top
may 30th
wow
coming over the top
yeah that's
definitely our best
footage yet it's beautiful
[Music]
we're gonna get as far as we can get
with the horses and
pack mule
and then
scott's gonna
drop us with our bags and we're gonna
keep going on foot over the mountain top
[Music]
now arthur i have to admit i would like
to see it with all these outfails that
i've run so far this spring
that was going to be a fun one to see
too
all right good luck guys
[Music]
yeah there's one place where we have to
cross an open steep face that still has
some snow on it
a lot of elk cross there we really don't
want to cross there
[Music]
a lot of people think elk are just elk
and then they all could do that so
maybe a wildlife battle just can't do it
those hoof prints
this out tracks all pounded through here
this is a hell of a trail hunter
[Music]
elk has taken all these roots
and it's just amazing to me that they
just go without knowing what's around
the corner
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just make sure to take your time on each
foot
[Music]
i mean i'm just totally amazed when
you're standing on top of a needle
mountain looking at those other points
along their trail all you can feel is
all
at the physical capabilities of these
animals
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she'll be coming round needle mountain
when she comes how does it go exactly
right
she'll be coming around him and when she
comes
coming around needle mountain when she
comes
coming around the mountain
i feel like i have a much greater
appreciation for the energy it takes for
these animals to do what they're doing
and the risks that they expose
themselves to
you know we're totally spent i think i i
knew it was tough but now i feel it in
my
bones and my muscles
it's humbling to feel what these animals
experience
[Music]
other than my camera traps this spot is
as close as i'll get to the migration
we need to show them traversing rivers
and their only time they're going to be
swimming rivers is when they're
migrating
you gotta wait a long time for the elk
show up at this spot but it's good
because i like hanging out and waiting
that's one of my favorite things to do
is just sit around
and look around
not do much
that's when the pictures get made is
when you stay
in one place for a while or you work the
same spot for a while
i do not want to affect the migration in
any way i just want to be an observer
and document it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be able to capture that vulnerable
moment right when they cross the river
feel lucky
super lucky like in the migration i'm
like
you know
living the dream i guess
[Music]
they go over this mountain and then drop
6000 foot to the river in less than 20
hours and then climb up the next
mountain which is another 6 000 foot
vertical gain i mean that's hard work
[Music]
you mention yellowstone to a lot of
people and they think of wolves and
they're around
but mainly we see grizzly bears
almost every day
traveling the trail picking over an
alcarcus grazing up on the plateaus
just a whole lot of grizzly bears
and the grizzly bears have figured out
that if they roll these rocks they can
eat
thousands of months
these moths make a migration in and out
of yellowstone park
it's just interesting for arthur and
myself and joe to think about how things
outside of the park sustain the life
that's in the park
as clear evidence that yellowstone isn't
contained by a box is the fact that it's
in me right now i really love that
landscape and it traveled with me back
to my studio and it informs what i do
here
[Music]
not only do the animals move from inside
the box out to other places but the
wonder that we feel when we're there
spreads far and wide including this
studio in connecticut you know over a
thousand miles away
[Music]
we were with scotland fevers and now
we're meeting up with lee and wes
livingston two local outfitters brothers
i could think of nothing better than go
spend a month up here by yourself
you don't have a satellite facebook
satellite facebook link yeah
i forgot it downstreamer
wes i thought you had it all
i do the only reason i do this is so you
believe that i know where i'm going
our callers
there's a couple of them and they hang
over here
yeah there ought to be some hiding up
there somewhere
for the next 10 miles or so all those
elk are on one trail heading towards the
southeast corner of yellowstone national
park that's why we're going to climb up
there
wes and i would be the first ones over
the mountain into the thoroughfare
it was a big adventure i love to go see
the elk you know in the spring
and then we follow it through the summer
when we take our pack trips we show
people these beautiful herds of elk up
on the high alpine meadows grazing then
on into the fall through the hunting
season we rely on the elk and then in
the winter time i go capture elk and net
gun out of helicopter put collars on
them for this research project here so
it's pretty much a year-round thing that
we're interacting with these elk
elk probably make up 85 percent of my
fall income
yeah they're they're a driving factor in
my life
yeah you think about it they're you're
messing with them damn near you're
around
i hope we find him but if we don't
doesn't mean it's a failure it just
means that
the elk aren't hanging out up on top of
the plateau when there's storm happening
like we are
imagine how jack feels
[Music]
that's a good one jack good boy
he says that's what it's all about
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's about to be august
um
and it's snowing sideways
on
oak summer range
july snow showers
make august flowers
probably be 75 degrees tomorrow
just another day in paradise
[Music]
we're gonna find some milk today
there are scientists who work in labs
and study things that you can manipulate
in petri dishes my petri dish is the
greater yellowstone
ecosystem so closest i'm ever gonna get
to seeing through a microscope into it
is getting on a horse and coming up to a
place like this and just trying to get
these glimpses
there's some out right there
there they are
that's a good group relaxing in the
grass
it's nice to see
seeing this with my own eyes up here
it's like i'm getting to see where the
whole thing begins
this is where the sun and the snow and
the rain make the grass that feeds these
migratory herds every year
it feels like i'm in the heart of
yellowstone
this is just one of nine different elk
migrations in the greater yellowstone
making up a total of over 20 000 elk
these migrations sprawl over an area
five times bigger than yellowstone
national park
what that means is that yellowstone
depends on that entire area and all the
land and all the people
[Music]
i've learned from joe's footage and
photographs that migration is a big part
of what makes animals wild
[Music]
and through james's work that we can't
think of yellowstone as a box defined by
its boundary
and personally i've started to believe
that these elk migrations are the
heartbeat the pulse of the greater
yellowstone ecosystem and i want to
spend the rest of my life being a part
of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you